welcome back in the last section we
talked about cross validation
um
for for the estimation of test error for
supervised learning
now we'll talk about a closely related
idea called the bootstrap
it's a powerful method for for assessing
uncertainty in estimates in particular
you forget the idea of standard errors
of an estimate and getting confidence
limits
wow it sounds like a powerful technique
rob are there any good books on the
topic
as a matter of fact no
rob has got a very uh famous book with
brad ephron on the bootstrap oh i've got
a very actually finger famous my
supervisor was brad ephron um who's now
our colleague
uh and he he's the inventor of the
bootstrap and
you
there's a conversation with brad in this
course which he talks about the
um
how he came to think of the bootstrap
the bootstrap was something he thought
of in 1979 and it's become one of the
most important techniques and statistics
in the last
30 years
so where does the name come from well
it's the idea of pulling yourself
up by your bootstraps um which is from a
fable by uh rudolph eric raspe the baron
fought
the adventures of
baron munchausen the baron had fallen to
the bottom of a deep lake
and couldn't get out
so he had an idea he thought he'd pull
himself up by his bootstraps his own
bootstraps and in the fable he managed
to pull himself out of the lake
um and save his life so that's that's
thought where the term bootstrap came
from and that's the term we're using
here
it's not the same as the term bootstrap
that one uses computer science to boot a
computer but it's the same idea you're
trying to pull yourself up from what
you've got
in this case we'll see the bootstrap
idea of a bootstrap is we're going to
use that the data itself to try to get
more information about our estimator
so let's
let's start with a simple example
suppose we have um
a fixed sum of money we want to invest
in two assets the yield returns x and y
where x and y are random quantities
depending on how the assets do
and we want to just we want to invest a
fraction
alpha of our money in x and the
remaining one minus alpha and y
we want to choose the fraction alpha to
minimize the total risk or the variance
of our investment
so we have random variables x and y we
want to choose the alpha to minimize the
variance of our of alpha x plus 1 minus
alpha times y
okay now in this population model you
can show that the best
the the best fraction alpha is given by
this formula
okay
uh sigma squared y that's the variance
of y there's the variance of x this is
the the covariance between x and y
okay and they're defined here so in
other words if we know the variance of x
variance of y and their covariance
then this is the
the best amount
proportion to put into
uh into x and remain goes into y to
minimize the total variance
okay so
those are population quantities
those are population quantities so
since the population quantities they're
not known to us
um in general
but if we if we have a
data set from the population that we're
under under study here
we can get an idea of these
of these quantities the variances and
the covariances
um
from the sample values from the from the
data set and then plug them into the
formula to get a
the alpha hat which is the which is the
proportion that we should invest in x
okay
so again we have if we have a sample of
x and y we can
get the empirical estimates of the
variances and covariances plug them in
and get a
an estimate of alpha
so
in this next slide we see
we've
we've created a simulated population
we've simulated
investments x and y
there's four different simulations here
each one containing 100 pairs of x and y
and for each one we take that data we
compute the variances and covariances
and we plug plug it into the formula to
get an
estimate for alpha
and here we see the four estimates of
alpha for the four panels
0.576 etcetera to 0.651 so they're
averaging around 0.6
okay
so if we want to get an idea of the
standard deviation of alpha hat we can
just repeat this process lots of times
let's say a thousand times okay so
we've got a thousand panels like this
each one gives us an alpha hat
from the formula on the previous slide
and we do this a thousand times
we take the standard standard error of
those
well
actually let's
do this a thousand times we'll go to the
look at the histogram in a couple of
slides
this this histogram on the left shows
the 1000 values over a thousand
simulations from this experiment
each one is a value of alpha hat
and the average around 0.6
that's called the sampling distribution
of that estimator right
and the true value actually since we
know in this case we're playing god
right we know the true variances and
covariances we know of the true alpha
and it's about point six i've indicated
here the purple line
the point six
and the the sampling distribution is
averaging around point six as we think
it should
um
so
the mean over the 1000 estimate should i
finish this okay i should say yeah i've
said this already
the here's the histogram we've seen
for the simulations actually these were
the values the parameters that we set
and that implied the true value of alpha
of 0.6 which was that middle value in
the histogram that's a true value of
alpha
okay
and now
we can also use this histogram to get to
the standard deviation of the estimates
just by picking the standard deviation
of those 1 000 values of alpha hat and
here here we've done that
and that's 0.083
so the standard error of alpha hat's
roughly 0.083
the standard error of an estimator
is the standard deviation in that
sampling distribution so if you're able
to recompute the estimator many many
times from new samples the standard
deviation
is called the standard error right so
if we repeat this experiment we expect
the each time that the on average alpha
hat would be about 0.6
and would vary by a standard deviation
of 0.083 right which we're seeing
in this histogram right it's averaging
about 0.08 and the standard deviation is
of well it's about 0.08 of this
histogram
okay
so that's all fine except
we can actually apply this with real
data if we had a sample of investments x
and y we don't actually have the ability
to sample from the population we we
don't have the population we have a
single sample
so most of statistics we don't have
access to the population
all we have is a sample
if we had access to the population we
actually wouldn't need statistics at all
for most part we could learn all we
wanted to know from the population but
in the real world we don't we have data
we don't we don't actually know the
populations from which that data arose
we have an idea of what it look might
look like but we don't we can't generate
more data
so we can't actually
we can't produce the histogram on the
left because we don't have the ability
to generate more data
but the bootstrap is going to try it's
going to mimic this process by sampling
not from the population but from this
from the data itself
so the data itself is going to act as
the population
so instead of obtaining independent data
sets from the population which we can't
do
without access to population
we're going to sample from the data
itself with replacement
and i'll
remind you in a minute what that means
but
basically with a sample from the data
set itself and then use those samples to
get an idea of the variability in the
same way that we use the samples from
the population
to produce this histogram
we're going to sample from the data
the data itself is the population
so
here's here's here's an idea of this is
an illustration of bootstrap sampling
which is sampling with replacement
i've created a data set here
just with three observations so we could
draw it on a single slide
here's our original data here's the
three observations
and now each of these is a bootstrap
sample bootstrap sample is drawn
with replacement of the same the same
size as the original data so the
original data here's got three
observations so we're going to draw
three observations with replacement what
does that mean it means that the chance
of each observation being sampled is the
same one-third but it's done with
replacement so imagine you put three
balls into a bag
say
numbered one two and three we we put our
hand in the bag we pull out one at
random maybe we'll get number one
that's our first observation now to get
our second observation we put the ball
back in the bag
that's why it's called with replacement
and we sample again from all three balls
so at every stage
each ball has the same probability of
being sampled and can be sampled more
than once at each
from stage one to end so here for
example
uh we've we've got observations three
twice an observation one once
observation two didn't get sampled at
all
okay in this second bootstrap sample
and we're drawing three samples from
these three observations we happen to
get two three and one so each
observation actually occurred once
in this
next sample we got observation two twice
and then observation one
so
just to summarize we sampled the same
number of observations as in our
original sample with replacement meaning
each each observation can appear more
than once or maybe not at all depending
on what happens as we we
draw the samples
so these are called bootstrap samples or
bootstrap data sets
and then
to each bootstrap data set we apply our
the estimator in this case our the alpha
this is the proportion of
investment x
we compute it from the sample just as we
computed it from the original sample
and we use the standard deviation of
these numbers to give us an idea of the
standard error of the standard deviation
of alpha alpha hat
so having drawn a thousand bootstrap
samples and got our thousand estimates
of alpha hat we can draw the histogram
as we did before let's go back to the
slide so now in the back on slide 29
the hist remember on the right excuse me
on the left is the histogram when we
sample from the population
the histogram of alpha hat values
we can't sample from the population
because we don't have the population so
we did bootstrap sampling we get the
histogram in the middle the blue
histogram
it looks very much like the one on the
left
it's averaging around 0.6 and its
variability is about the same as
we got
from the population as a matter of fact
well so over here we've got the
box plots of the the alpha hat values
the true ones from the
sample from the population and the
bootstrap ones and they're looking
pretty similar
they're averaging
around 0.6 so the bootstrap is a little
lower
in this case
but
in general this gives you a pretty good
idea of what we would get if we could
sample from the population in the
standard error estimate let's see do we
have that in the next
back here
yeah the standard error
estimate is 0.087
which is similar we got .083 before when
we used to sample from the population so
the bootstrap is
used the data itself as the population
and got us a good estimate of the
standard error very similar to the one
we'd get if we could sound from the
population
so we've seen some examples of a booth
drop in simple problems in the next
section we'll talk about the method of
more generality